من اطلاله نجاه الصغيره بعد غياب طويل على
المسرح وتكريم زعيم الفن العربي عادل امام
والسنديان دمشقيه منى واصف وصاحبه السعاده
اسعاد يونس الى فوز الشامي بالاغنيه
المفضله اليكم ابرز اللحظات المؤثره في
جوي اواردز
[موسيقى]
2024 حمل حفل جوي اواردز 2024 الذي شهدته
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض العديد من
المفاجات واللحظات المؤثره التي حققت
تفاعلا واسعا على منصات التواصل ومن
ابرزها غناء المطربه المصريه نجاه الصغيره
في اول ظهور مباشر لها على المسرح منذ
سنوات طويله المطربه المصريه انشدت مقطعا
من احدى اغانيها الايقونيه عيون القلب
وتسلمت تكريما خاصا من تركي ال الشيخ رئيس
هيئه الترفيه
[موسيقى]
بالسعوديه
ي ما
بتلا يا
حبيبي ليله جوي اوردز هذا العام كانت
حافله بالتكريم لنجوم عرب وعالميين من
الطراز الرفيع منحوا جائزه الانجاز مدى
الحياه التي فاز بها كل من انطوني هوبكنز
كيفن كوسنر كوينزي جونز رابح صقر صاحبه
السعاده اسعاد يونس والسنديان الدمشقيه
منى واصف يعني انا حسيت انه شي من تاريخ
طلع هيك مسني حسسني لما كنت احلم انه شو
بدي يكون وكان من ابرز المكرمين في حفل
جوائز جوي اواردز الفنان المصري عادل امام
بجائزه زعيم الفن العربي وتسلم التكريم
نجلاه رامي ومحمد
امام كما فازت نخبه من نجوم الشرق والغرب
العرب والعالميين بجائزه صناع الترفيه
الفخريه ومنهم المطربه اللبنانيه نجوى كرم
وصناع المسلسل المصري الذي حقق نجاحا
كبيرا في موسم دراما رمضان
2023 تحت الوصايه ومنحت جوائز جوي اواردز
بناء على تصويت الجمهور لرياضيين ومؤثرين
وفنانين عرب بعض هذه الجوائز كان مفاجئا
كجائزه الاغنيه المفضله التي فاز بها
المغني السوري الشاب الشامي عن اغنيه يا
ليلو يا العين وعبر على طريقته الخاصه عن
نشوه الفوز من ولد بيجلس
حون لحدا عم يتكرم اهم حفل موجود بالشرق
الاوسط دموع منى واصف وابناء الزعيم ونشوه
الشامي بالفوز لم تكن استثناء في ليله
شهدت الكثير من اللحظات المؤثره والرسائل
التي اراد النجوم ايصالها على الهواء
كاعلان اصاله مشاركتها جائزه الفنانه
المفضله مع انغام لتثبيت الصلح الذي حدث
بينهما مؤخرا لان نجمه
كبيره وتستحق كل تكريم بتستحق كل محبه
وتقاسم اصاله مع طريقها طارق العريان
الهواء ذاته في مسرح بكر الشدي الذي شهد
حفل توزيع جوائز جوي اوردز 2044 في الرياض
وتحدث فيه العريان عن جديده الجزء الثالث
من فيلم اولاد ريز والذي تم تصوير العديد
من مشاهده في العاصمه السعوديه ايه يا
اساطير عين السيره ده احنا اد رز
ستوب كما عبرت شيرين عبد الوهاب عن شوقها
الكبير للقاء من وصفتهم بعائلتها الكبيره
بعد ميدلي مختار من اشهر اغانيها بدات تشع
بالسعاده وهي تؤديه وكانها تقول ها انا ذا
لقد
عدت واختتم الفنان المصري عمرو دياب الحفل
بطريقه طريفه انا بشكركم عشان دي النهايه
والختام وكان المفروض ينزلهم حاجات نازل
في حاجات هتنزل بالونات وحركات كده عاوز
نزل ايه مش عارف قولي
كده